welcome everyone this is Brian Green
coming to you from Columbia University
in my office in the physics department
here welcome to this live stream from
the world Science Festival and today
we're going to be talking about a
subject that's near and dear to my heart
and to the heart of many theoretical
physicists and I do emphasize
theoretical for the most part for
reasons that many of you already know
and we become clear in our conversation
and that is a subject of unification the
subject of putting together gravity and
quantum mechanics into a unified
framework that would allow us to blend
together our deepest understanding of
physics that has emerged over the course
of many many decades really about a
century or so during the early part of
the 20th century when these ideas first
bubbled up and the conversation today
will be with one Mal Desa who is really
one of the great leaders of the field
tremendous impact across the board so
we'll spend some time talking about the
issues of how difficult it is to put
gravity and quantum mechanics together
why that is how an approach that many of
you know of perhaps through popular
books or television shows maybe some
I've been involved with called String
Theory May well be the answer that we
been looking for but there are issues
that need to be resolved and we'll talk
about what some of those issues are and
some of the
amazing aspects of the theory that have
come to light in the last you know 5 10
15 years that have really convinced us
that this approach is mathematically
rich and has the capacity to give some
dramatic revolutionary insights into the
nature of the world the nature of
reality so let me me bring in Juan who
is the Carl fineberg professor in the
school of Natural Sciences at The
Institute for advanced study he has made
tremendous contributions across the
board in string theory quantum gravity
we'll talk about perhaps his most famous
discovery which is called the ads CFT
correspondence which relates to a
stunning idea in physics called
holography or the whole graphic
principle and perhaps we'll even get to
a result that puts together the ideas of
wormholes and quantum entanglement which
goes by the cryptic name epr equals erer
so let's bring Juan in good to see you
Juan where are you at the moment yeah
nice to see you I'm here in my office in
Princeton New Jersey and that is at the
institute for Advan stud Institute for
Advance study yes yeah and of course as
many in our audience will know that's
where Einstein spent many decades of his
life the last Decades of his life and he
was intent on finding what he called and
what we call in a somewhat different use
of the terminology a unified theory our
way of framing it differs from
Einstein's of course because Einstein
was thinking of putting together gravity
and the electromagnetic force we want to
put together everything including
quantum mechanics which Einstein had his
own issues with but this modern framing
of trying to have this unified
description of gravity and quantum
mechanics
is there any chance that we're asking
for too much is it possible that we just
have these two descriptions of the world
one for the big stuff one for the small
stuff we just have to live with
it well I don't think so I mean the the
the world uh is one thing we divide it
into big and small and it has to work
together and the the other point is that
um now gravity is important for big
things but uh earlier in the history of
the universe the whole universe was much
smaller and gravity was still important
and if we continue going back and back
it reaches a point where uh both gravity
and quantum mechanics are important at
the same time uh so if we really want to
understand the beginning of the universe
uh we are forced to this question of
trying to put together gravity and
quantum mechanics I would say that this
is the biggest practical question let me
say practical in the sense of um
scientific and in terms of curiosity of
trying to understand how they Universe
began that that is the main question why
we study quantum gravity so trying to
put gravity and quantum mechanics and
you know I I I give a similar answer
when people ask about you know why it's
important to put gravity and quantum
mechanics together and why we think that
there has to be some sort of unified
theory black holes is another domain
that we'll probably spend a little bit
of time talking about presumably you'd
throw that into the mix as well as an
arena that requires these two theories
to come together
yes yes black black holes uh it's
another situation especially in the
interior of black holes so in the
interior of black holes again SpaceTime
collapses and become small in some way
and quantum mechanics and gravity both
become
important and so hole Yeah if you're
outside the black hole then the those
effects are very small especially for
the black holes that we see in the sky
and so I mean in principle you and I
could have just crossed over the Event
Horizon of a black hole at least in some
incarnations of our understanding and we
wouldn't have even known it because for
the black holes big enough the effects
at large distances are not significant
but if you want to understand the center
of a black yeah yeah in the interior
it's it's a different story that's right
yeah we are falling for example into the
black hole that is at the center of uh
the the Galaxy that appeared in the
picture in this famous black hole
picture m87 yeah so that would take us
maybe an hour a few hours to get into
this Singularity right so hopefully we
haven't just crossed over but if we have
this live stream will abruptly come to
an end in in roughly an hour or so so so
you're right of course that it's it's a
human artificial division between what
we call Big and what we call small but
it certainly has been a fruitful
division because we've done pretty well
at describing these two Realms when we
think of them as independent of other so
let's start with the big where Einstein
really became Einstein you know with his
general theory of relativity you know
just give us a a thumbnail sketch of of
how Einstein wants us to think about
gravity the force it's most relevant for
big
things well the The crucial idea is to
think as gravity as been a consequence
of the curvature of SpaceTime so the
idea is that SpaceTime uh is like a
medium that can stretch and deform um
and that when we have gravity it's
reflecting that deformation of SpaceTime
so for example the big Earth deforms the
fabric of SpaceTime and makes clocks run
at different speeds at different heights
and uh that that that's that's what the
deformation means in particular and uh
that deformation sort of causes us to
want to go down in the what we call the
gravitational field but
um yeah so that's uh how Einstein views
SpaceTime and uh well this theory of
course has many interesting
consequences perhap the two most famous
and important ones are that the universe
is expanding and that black holes can
exist and so Einstein developed the
general theory of relativity before he
got to the institute for Van study that
was when he was still you know in
Germany you know finished the theory in
1915 and of course I think as most in
our audience knows Einstein's theory has
been tested to Fantastic Precision I
mean we still see tests coming you know
in the last few years right I mean
gravitational waves I mean were you were
you among those who thought the
gravitational waves would ever be
detected I certainly would I was not in
that camp I thought that it was a Fool's
errand well I I've heard about
gravitational wave detectors through my
career they first building them they
were first building them they were say
well they are not sensitive enough yet
we'll have to make them more sensitive
and I thought that we would still get a
few more iterations of this but yeah it
was wonderful when they actually saw
them yeah and you already made mention
of the fact that we finally now have
direct images from the event rizon
telescope of of black hole so yeah yeah
that's right yeah and the this
gravitational waves uh are coming from
collisions of black holes and they agree
in great detail with the the predictions
of Einstein theory so it's one so not
not the most interesting aspect about
detecting gravity waves was where those
gravity waves were coming from they were
coming from very massive black
holes and and are giving us uh the best
I think probe of the geometry near the
Horizon of black holes yeah absolutely
now it it's curious just as a side note
that Einstein himself was quite
skeptical about the exist of black holes
there papers I don't know in the 30s or
maybe early 40s where Einstein tried to
argue that black holes were some very
special mathematical feature of the
general theory of relativity but You'
never actually realize them in the real
world and similarly for gravitational
waves he was definitely on the fence
about whether he even thought that they
were a real implication of the general
theory of relativity so I mean what's up
with the great genius not trusting the
implications of his own Theory well the
the theory is based on a beautiful idea
and the questions are are the questions
are relatively simple but it's actually
quite difficult to interpret the
solutions of these equations and then
they have surprising Solutions like the
black hole solution uh which took many
years to be properly understood and um
yeah it's h it's quite interesting to to
understand the history of classical
black holes it took about 50 years to
properly understand the classical
geometry black hols um and of course
there was a key work of pandr and and
hogin and others that really clarified a
lot the our modern understanding of the
classical geometry of black holes yeah I
guess Penrose you know really was a
turning point in our understanding of
black holes because using mathematical
methods that most physicists were not
familiar with getting away from the
intricate small scale local geometry to
the global topological properties of the
SpaceTime he convincingly argued that
black holes should be a ubiquitous
feature of the world you know yeah they
form generically not in simple
spherically symmetric situations and so
on yeah exactly so so here we have this
beautiful theory that even goes beyond
Einstein's own expectations in terms of
its capacity to describe real things out
there in the real world the general
theory of relativity let's turn to the
other end of the Spectrum which is
quantum mechanics and you know some of
our audience will know you know Einstein
wrote the first or perhaps the second
paper on quantum mechanics and that's
the paper that I got the Nobel Prize for
the photoelectric effect but again was
not happy with how that theory developed
I mean where did his discomfort come
from well quantum mechanics is a
probabilistic Theory so it's a theory
where you don't know exactly what's
going to happen even if you know have
perfect knowledge of the initial state
of the system as much as you can
possibly have then you can predict the
result of future experiments and this is
what bothered him it it seemed to him
that quantum mechanics was an effective
Theory then there would be a more
fundamental Theory underline quantum
mechanics in the same way that let's say
in thermodynamics you we have um for
example Notions like entropy like heat
and so on that um come from more
fundamental more F comes from more
fundamental description and um so um and
this is this is what I think bother
Einstein to think that nature of the
fundamental level would be the would be
quantum mechanics and yeah it's a I
would say this is a bother that maybe
some people still share I I I'm not sure
people are completely comfortable with
quantum mechanics I mean we all know
what the rules R are Einstein of course
understood what the rules are for
quantum mechanics it's not that he just
philosophically didn't like the rules
and thought that there might be some
deeper underlining real
reality and there may be right I mean
you know there might be there might well
be yes you know Gerardo T you know
another Nobel lawyer has certainly spent
some time trying to develop what that
underlying Theory might be but you know
it's interesting you know as you go from
one generation of physicists to the next
to the next things that were so
problematic philosophically speaking to
an earlier generation the Next
Generation grows up with the ideas and I
presumably because of that they don't
have the kind of resistance so what
becomes you know in the early days what
is so problematic for people to accept
the Next Generation just kind of shrugs
their shoulders and and and goes forward
with it I mean of course I mean you
grown up with quantum mechanics
completely do do you have any discomfort
with the theory at all um yeah I I I do
but I of course I learned the rules and
uh I learned that the rule is to shut up
and calculate don't don't ask this
questions and that it hasn't been so far
very productive to ask these questions
though that there was the wonderful work
of B and B inequalities that are B
basically based on these
questions and um yeah so I I
think I'm still somewhat comfortable
with quantum mechanics I felt as I was
studying physics that I understood
everything I understood electromagnetism
classical physics when I got to Quantum
Mechanics I felt I stopped understanding
completely stopped getting I don't know
the more intuitive understanding yeah I
could follow the mathematics I could
understand the mathematics but and I
have a question along those lines though
when I took quantum mechanics as a
undergraduate physics major they did not
mention the word entanglement something
that we'll talk talk a little bit about
later on when you took quantum mechanics
was entanglement part of the curriculum
no no it wasn't yeah it's interesting
how it shifts I think now it's probably
an important part is maybe one of the
first few things people learn yeah and
it's because it it has really it's
important has has grown I think we are
just applying quantum mechanics in a new
way now so I guess when quantum
mechanics was first invented okay so it
was applied to to understand atoms and
chemistry and and well of course
subatomic particles and so on and and
that focuses you on some aspects of
quantum mechanics and suddenly
entanglement is part of that but not not
not crucial um now we are in the time
where people are thinking about uh you
know complex Quantum materials they are
thinking about quantum computers and
things like that where entanglement is
is fundamental and and very important
for understanding how things work so
it's interesting though that Schrodinger
way back in the 19 late 20s early 30s
said something like entanglement is not
a feature it is the feature of quantum
mechanics that distinguishes it from a
classical worldview so even back then
there were some of the pioneers of
quantum mechanics who knew that
entanglement this idea that widely
separated objects particles so to speak
can act as though they're next to each
other that that idea was at the heart of
quantum mechanics yeah yeah know it
definitely was recognized it was
recognized by Einstein the famous
Einstein podowski Ros and paper that you
mentioned before um but it was a thought
experiment so was mainly for them it
yeah it was mainly a feature of quantum
mechanics like a thought experiment now
now it's now it's a reality right there
there are devices where this is
important yeah I mean once you harness
something and you start to apply it it
takes on sort of a different ontological
status in terms of it being actually
real of being really out there um like
with general relativity quantum
mechanics has been tested to
incredible accuracy I mean I like to
quote you know the calculation and the
measurements of you know the electron
Magnetic Moment I mean it's just an
insane agreement to many many decimal
places I don't know 10 11 12 13 decimal
places something of that sort so there
can be little doubt that quantum
mechanics is telling us something real
about the world however strange it might
be probabilities and tangman all that
stuff there can also be little doubt
that general relativity is telling us
something real about the world through
you know going way back to the
observation of the bending of Starlight
by the Sun but you know as we mentioned
gravitational waves black holes and so
forth what then is the issue I mean why
why is it hard for these two theories to
play well together to
coexist well we as they are currently
understood and tested experimentally
they appli at different landens scales
and for different objects so we never
apply them at the same time yeah and um
so gravity um is what we normally call
the field Theory so has this the
geometry of SpaceTime is something
extended and as you go to shorter and
shorter distances there are this sort of
fluctuations of SpaceTime um that
according
to to to the classical Theory and and
our understanding of quantum mechanics
we expect that uh the interactions
between those small fluctuations becomes
larger and larger as you go to smaller
and smaller distances and so that that
means that um at very short distances
quantum mechanics and gravity should
have some
trouble working together these distances
are much much much smaller than the
distances we can measure today with our
biggest particle detectors with particle
accelerators our sort of most powerful
microscopes so they're super t tiny so
we don't have any
experimental
um experimental contradiction or problem
um that so the only problems are if you
wish theoretically if we try to
extrapolate equation equations backwards
as to the beginning of time we have a
problem because of this issue or to the
interior of black holes where again we
have a problem according to this this um
and so we would like to have a more
complete understanding of nature so at
some level it's a theoretical question
we have two principles that we we we
have of general relativity and one to
mechanics and we want to put them
together in in to a single Theory so and
the hope would be that the problem is
constrained enough that the the theory
would be unique or there wouldn't be too
many possibilities and and hopefully it
will have some experimental consequences
that we would be able to check I mean
that that's the general idea of and if
we put but if you put some numbers into
what you just said and if we go down to
that tiny length scale where the problem
theoretically would arise a so-called
plank length roughly 10 Theus 33 cmers
if you compare that as you say with the
distance scales that we can reach with
our most powerful microscopes which are
powerful accelerators what can we reach
I don't know 10 to minus 18 centimeters
I don't know something yeah so yeah
that's right so one way to think about
it is to think about the distance scale
uh in terms of powers of 10 right so we
have to go some distance in powers of 10
to get to the smallest distance we can
measure today and we have to continue
the same distance in powers of 10 to get
the to the plank to the that smallest
distance of quantum gravity right so
that's that's that's an
audacious problem to face as a theorist
right to yes yes it's a wild
extrapolation it might be that you know
the world is not quantum mechanical at
those scales that that there is
something completely different uh that's
uh certainly a possibility ility so the
the game is to just assume that try to
take the principles we have and come up
with the simplest generalizations that
that puts together these principles now
nature might choose to do something else
or yeah I mean it's fun to ask you these
questions because they're often the ones
that people try to put me on the hot
spot or the hot seat when I'm talking
about these ideas so I'd love to hear
you know how you handle them as well is
it is it you know
a Fool's errand is it a mistake as a
theorist to spend so much effort trying
to LEAP say 15 16 17 orders of magnitude
when in in in distance you know going to
16 orders of magnitude smaller than we
have any experimental input is it a
mistake to make that wild leap to try to
figure out how to put gravity in quantum
mechanics together is it simply too
early in the history of science to do
that well it might be we we don't know
so the
the if the problem was very
unconstrained in the sense that you
found lots and lots of different
solutions and you know anything goes and
you could modify the the rules we have
in any possible way that I think then it
would be um so the reason for thinking
it might not be is is if you don't find
many consistent ways of uh modifying the
rules that we have to put these two
things together that that I think is one
way in which you could think perhaps you
might find the answer yeah so I think
right now the goal is to find an answer
so a theory that um that puts uh
together gravity and quantum mechanics
and even there we I would say we don't
have a complete satisfactory solution so
of course string theory is very exciting
but there are questions we don't
understand even uh using string theory
like the beginning of the Big Bang sure
well let's get into String Theory since
since you mentioned the answer natural
segue to do that strength the as a
potential solution you know I was a
graduate student in 1984 when the first
if you will modern breakthrough for
string theory happened the famous green
and Schwarz paper different green no on
the end Michael Green not me uh paper
where were you in
1984 um I was um in high school yeah
you're in high school right so so I
didn't know about this right so you
presumbly weren't following any of of
this stuff not
that um and so yeah go ahead please yeah
String Theory should is a really a
theory under construction so we know
some aspects of the theory and we don't
know other aspects
so for sure for sure I mean and I'd love
to get into a little bit of the detail
if you don't mind if we could do a a
brisk walk through of the ideas from a
historical standpoint I think that's a
reasonable thing to do because there are
various people who were watching this
who may have followed String Theory at
this or that moment in the development
maybe dropped out perhaps heard
something from one of the TR detractors
out there in the world and got sort of
turned off or something so if we go back
to 84 I mean the basic idea of string
theory is little vibrating filaments
vibrating Loops that you know unify
things in the sense that all particles
arise from the same idea the different
vibrational patterns of a of a vibrating
filament a little tiny vibrating
filament but from the question of of how
String Theory resolves the problem of
putting gravity in quantum mechanics
together I often say that it kind of
gives you a shortest distance scale you
can't go smaller than the smallest
ingredient in the theory and if the size
of that ingredient is on par with the
size at which the problem emerges you
kind of cut the problem out of reality
is that how you describe it or what's
your way of giving a a brief idea of how
String Theory resolves the tension yeah
that might be a way to say um maybe
perhaps well I would say slightly I
would say some other thing might be
perhaps a little too technical but no go
for it some analogy with the theory of
weak interactions so when the weak
interactions were first uh discussed it
was through the so-called Pharmacy
Theory it was a theory similar to GR in
the sense that general relativity in the
sense that as you go went to um
theoretically you could predict that as
you go to shorter and shorter distances
the weak interactions should become more
stronger and stronger and that theory
predicted that uh the weak interaction
should become very strong at the
distances we currently are exploring
with the particle acceler to the LHC uh
should become very strong
but the then uh a theory uh was
developed for the weak interactions
where something new happens at this
slightly smaller slightly lower scale
lower energy scale uh that there would
be new particles the W and set B on of
the weak interactions and those were
discovered you know in the the 8S and um
and so what happens is that above those
energies the the theory becomes well
it's weekly couple and uh the coupling
continues to be more or less constant
and then that theory could make sense at
even shorter distances and in string
theory something roughly similar happens
in the sense that there is a new scale
uh which is the mass of the first
excited St state of the string and then
after that scale the the nature of going
to short distances changes we don't just
have gravity we have some let's say
stringy version of gravity or something
else um and then the theory can be
weekly
coupled beyond that and exactly what
distances mean Beyond below the scale is
unclear and so you could say in some
sense that that that's the shortest
distance um but yeah so that's so that
that's a historical comparison let's say
between how String Theory modifies
gravity and how uh the modern theory of
weak interactions modifies the firming
Theory right so you're saying much as in
the weakend interactions yeah new
particles and new physics comes into
play right when there would have been a
problem right it's actually before so I
wanted to emphasize at least in weekly
couple String Theory it's before the
slightly before there is a problem
modification and this is important
because then it gives a theory that
weekly couple so it's analyzable through
simple methods right and those simple
methods of course are are what we call
pertubation Theory so that's the string
theory of the 80s so that exactly so
we'll we'll go into the 90s and Beyond
very shortly but just to sort of
emphasize that point you mentioned the
mass scale the first excited state of a
vibrating string has a certain amount of
energy in Mass that's about 10 to the 19
times the mass of a proton just to give
people a feel that we are way way Beyond
any of the energy scales much as we
described before that we're way smaller
than any the distance scales that we can
we can Pro so these are just theoretical
ideas nevertheless on paper they seem to
work right I I would like to mention
something that um well also related to
the history that yeah String Theory
really did not start in 84 but it
started earlier trying to understand
interaction yeah yeah yeah trying to
start trying to understand strong
interactions in the late 60s and the
motivation was really experimental in
the sense that people in particle
accelerators observed objects that
behave like strings and um these are
real objects so there are some real
objects that you produce in particle
accelerators that really behave like uh
the relativistic string very similar to
the strings that we have in string
theory yeah um yeah so now we view them
as um as tubes of color electric flux um
so in the theory of modern Quant the
modern theory is the theory of quantum
electrodynamics but that's an example of
a theory uh well that's an example of
relativistic strings so yeah the strings
we are talking about here are not a
complete uh you know thing that does not
exist in reality there is something in
reality that is somewhat similar um and
these strings are an extrapolation
theoretical further theoretical
construction based on an idea that uh on
strengths that really exist yeah
absolutely I mean it is important to
recognize that these ideas didn't just
pop into people's wild imagination they
were motivated by data in the 1960s for
sure but um the amazing thing is and you
know this is a point that Ed Whitten
does still emphasize but he emphasized
it really forcefully back in the 80s
when I was a graduate student you know
he emphasized that you start with this
theory of vibrating filaments of
vibrating string
and when you analyze that theory you
find a vibrational pattern that has just
the right properties to transmit force
of gravity the so-called graviton
particle and so if you didn't know the
general theory of relativity before you
knew String Theory at least in principle
a sufficiently clever person could have
extracted the general theory of
relativity out of string
theory I mean
[Music]
that's that's amazing you you know um
and so it does give you some sense you
know both from the experimental
motivation early on and then from the
theoretical qualities of this theory of
vibrating strings that you you can't
help but feel you're going in the in the
right direction you know so that was
sort of the 19 now now of course you
have to make contact between any
proposed Theory and things hopefully
that you can observe with the technology
that you have have at hand and one of
the issues that made that difficult
beyond what we've already mentioned that
the theory really flexes its muscle
shows its true colors and Tiny distance
scales large energies is that the theory
has mathematics that tells us that there
should be more spatial
Dimensions than the ones that that we
know about I mean I found this
incredibly exciting in the 80s as a
graduate student especially because I
came to the subject from a more
geometrical math itical side of things
and once I saw that higher dimensional
spaces and all the wonderful technology
of of Romanian geometry and and topology
that all had a home I was I was hooked
from from that point of view but when
you learn that the theory had extra
Dimensions was that an exciting idea or
was it like whoa I mean are we are we
still talking about physics here or are
we going off the deep end yeah know I
think that was interesting well when I
learned it it was already well known
well it was known within I learned it
from the some popular articles on string
theory but I mean when did you start to
actually actually work on on String
Theory what year was that um well it's
about 1990 perhaps 1990 okay yeah was my
undergraduate
but I yeah I think it's interesting that
that in strength Theory the equations of
strength the are a little more
constraint are more constraining than
the questions of general relativity in
the sense that they they constraint the
dimensionality of SpaceTime for example
um that's which is a beautiful thing
except the constraint is not the one
that perhaps we would have naively
thought right yeah naively would have
expected four but 10 in some sense comes
with a gift that well the what you were
saying about from the geometry of the
internal Dimensions you could get
various laws of physics so it it's gives
you more kind of opportunities to
connect the string theory with reality
right so at the I guess in the 80s it
was believed that there would be a small
number of possibilities well that's the
thing exactly when I was a graduate
student I mean the original paper of
candell's horard strominger and Whitten
had introduced how to curl up these
extra Dimensions into so-called cabio
manifolds cabia shapes and only listed I
don't know like five possible ways to
curl up the extra
dimensions and so our goal was if we can
just find one other way of curling them
up that gives rise to say three three
families of particles a quality of
particle physics that was unexplained
and still really is unexplained at the
time but was experimentally proven to be
part of the data of the world how
exciting would that be so we work day
and night to try to analyze the really
the one example that that Yao himself
with a student at that time T it put
forward and we thought maybe this is it
maybe these are this is the shape for
the extra dimensions because they're
only a handful known the problem of
course is people found more
possibilities for the extra Dimensions
over time I mean did you know and and
the number grew over time number of
possible
shapes was that at all disheartening to
you it was initially it was
disheartening to me but for you because
I'd work so hard on one specific example
and you're like why why bother if
there's so many you know well yeah in
some sense I I I
when I came into the field the the
people had already found lots of
examples and this field had developed a
lot and had become you didn't have your
heart broken you didn't have your heart
broken yeah I didn't have my heart
broken I just uh was kind of scared by
the amount of data that was already
there in all this calavia shapes that I
worked on some other aspects of the
theory so some right um the aspects that
involved well what happens with black
holes
and other types of questions yeah I
don't want to get to that I think it's
still still something that confus
continues to confuse us today so now now
now there is you could put a positive
spin on this in the sense that you could
say well if you have so many things but
we can explain you know small numbers
and things like that well maybe we can
spend a moment on that so-called
anthropic reasoning since you you you
bring it up because you're absolutely
right you know on one end you can say oh
my God string Theory just has too many
possible universes that it might give
rise to on the other hand if you're
facing a number like the dark energy
which is this measured well indirectly
measured quality of the world that
there's an energy suffusing space with a
very strange amount you know in in in
appropriate units it's like a decimal
point with you know you know hundreds of
zeros and then a one at the end of it
you know and we can't imagine how we
could explain that from first principles
because most calculations start with one
squ of 2 pi e thing how how do you get
such a tiny number but if you have
perhaps a Multiverse with many universes
each with a different value for the dark
energy well somewhere out there you're
gonna find the value that we've measured
so at least in principle you have an
explanation some people hate that idea
consider it a copout or no longer doing
science what's your take on mult ierse
and using it to explain things that
puzzle us well I I think one point is
that it's interesting that in string
theory the cosmical constant is
calculable or at least given some name
for the
dark you can calculate it so they it
depends on this internal shapes
yes and um yeah I I'm a little I have
some certainly I find it logical that
this is the way nature could work that
there might be some Observer constraints
anthropic constraints we have them in
some some aspects of physics in biology
is super important but in in
um
the the the what the problem is that
it's a bit it makes the goal of making a
prediction more difficult because he
saying that well there are all these
possibilities and then okay what we
measure is just one of them but you're
not would be very hard to find that one
what precise shapes correspond to this
particular one that we measured so I I
find it a bit uh disheartening in the
sense of it makes our the task of
finding an experimentally verifiable
prediction harder seem at least seem
harder yeah now we probably have to
think more and uh and uh and there will
be perhaps correlations between
parameters or I I yeah so that's or
maybe even yeah and that's probably one
reason people hate it that you say well
okay I explained everything yeah so it's
not it's not I think it's not an
explanation until you understand the
theory well enough to understand what
these possibilities really are not not
just at the bag level but at the more
concrete level yeah I mean and if we
were one day I mean this some people
would say this is you know an idol hope
but I think the goal perhaps is if it so
happens that reality does make use of a
Multiverse it's a possibility if there
are many Realms out there our charge
would be ideally to find some kind of
way of predicting which universes are
more likely higher measure is the
language that we often use relative to
others but you know it's it's it's it's
a work in progress like you're saying
yes that that that that's related well
we mentioned before the this problem of
predicting what what happened in the
beginning of the big bang and yeah and
there are there are a bunch of questions
about quantum gravity in this regime
like which involved predicting uh things
that are constant in our universe so if
there are many different possibilities
of our universe let's say different
possible values for the mass of the
electron or the mass of the proton so
how do you uh assign a probability to
each of them is it reasonable to assign
a probability
and and and I think our current
understanding of the theory does not
allow us to calculate these
probabilities we we fail kind of
miserably when we try to we get very
confused and so on so that that's why I
was saying that well string the the in
progress in principle probably if we
understand the theory well enough and we
develop it well enough we'll be we will
be able to calculate these probabilities
and then check whether they agree with
what we see or not but we we are not
only unable to calculate them if we make
some estimates and the native estimates
they they're way off so especially when
we are talking about eternal inflation
and such ideas yeah and so this
certainly is an arena in which look I
mean in the most coarse language one can
say so far string theory has failed to
provide the mathematical apparatus to
make definitive predictions you know
this is the shape for the extra
Dimensions or this is the likely shape
for the this is the likely particles
that come out of it and so forth and as
you say it's a work in progress we just
have to own up to the things that still
need work in fact it's exciting because
the next Generation has deep things to
work on black holes however provide an
arena in which string theory has made
remarkable progress I mean if I was
going to point to one area in which
string theory has really answered
questions and and in a way that I think
many of us perhaps wouldn't have thought
by the year 2023 we would have these
kinds of insights it is in the arena of
black holes and and one of the the
issues there has to do with the
so-called entropy of black HS and this
idea that Stephen Hawking and
beckenstein and others in the 70s
developed in this idea that black holes
have certain kind of qualities degrees
of freedom if you will internally and
you can count those as Stephen Hawking
did but in a manner that was a very
delicate blending of general relativity
and Quantum methods it kind of just
skirted by using those two tools in a
way that barely gets you to the answer
string theory has has radically changed
that right I mean can you just give a
sense of the work of well I think so let
let me say a little bit more the about
the history so the yeah um so hin found
that black holes have finite temperature
and then um just the ordinary loss of
thermodynamics implies that if you know
the energy of an object in the case of
black hole that would be EMC squ so the
mass of the black hole and you know the
temperature then you can from these two
things you can calculate the so-called
entropy which is the
so this is entropy that is a
thermodynamic object and we know from
bolman and statistical mechanics that
such an entropy should come from in in a
Quantum Theory list or in a microscopic
Theory should come from the number of
ways or states or configurations of the
system um so the black hole had to have
this number of configurations which
would be very big um so because the
entropy is proportional to the area in
terms divided by this minimum distance
that we were talking about before called
the plank length and so that works out
to be a huge number for microscopic
black hole so it's an entropy much much
bigger than the entropy of any ordinary
object of the same
size and um so it was mysterious because
general relativity gives us just one
black hole solution and not only that
but the black hole solution seems to be
like an attractor so if you perturb it a
little bit it goes over back to the same
solution yeah um so so now we so in the
1996 uh so string CH and Buffa found uh
some special black holes for which um
you could calculate the the entropy by
counting micro States so there was a
they started with a certain black hole
and changed the couplings of the theory
and and then found some configuration of
strings and brains but various objects
that you could whose number you could
calculate very precisely
um and it matched what you got you you
get using the Hawking calculation so
this was viewed as an amazing um well
it's still an amazing totally amazing
result in strength Theory and
consistency of the theory so you as you
said you started with the vibrating
loops and this and that and then you get
this black hole entropy formula that was
a mystery you know since the 70s when
beckenstein and haw first start started
talking about this um so so was really
understood that string theory was doing
something deep and it was mysteriously
consistent and um and this this type of
calculations were re refined and
extended in various directions um and so
for example you could calculate even
corrections to the to the beckenstein
and Hwy answer both from gravity and
from this microscopic counting and they
agreed and anyway so whole whole story
that is pretty amazing um
yeah and uh
then then another development was trying
to understand better so dynamics of
black holes what happens when you send
something in and how how these various
States kind of are are changed and and
develop under time Evolution so in in
quantum physics we we have some states
and then as time evolves you go from one
state to another and try to understand
this in in more
detail and yeah so
that that kind of led to this idea of
ads uh
well the adcf correspondence which is
some some way of understanding a bit
more about the Dynamics of black holes
so before we jump to ads CFT which is of
course your your great breakthrough I
just want to spend a little bit more
time unpacking what you just mentioned
you know in terms of the entropy of
black Hool so you know it it's kind of
curious that the entropy is proportional
to the area of the black hole right I
mean you know when you're talking about
entropy roughly people can think you
know the amount of disorder as you say
the the number of microscopic
configurations that are compatible with
the macroscopic qualities of whatever it
is that you're studying you would think
that that should be proportional to the
volume of whatever it is that you're
looking at because more volume there's
more ways that things can be packed
together and and and yet it is
proportional to the area and and that's
telling us something pretty pretty deep
which I guess is in its modern
Incarnation and SC in the So-Cal
holographic principles you say a couple
words about that yes yes
so so there there seems to be a kind of
dimensional reduction in the sense of
where the degrees of freedom are so if
you think about the quantum field Theory
so an ordinary theory that we use for
examp for example to describe particle
physics we think of those theories as
having degrees of freedom or let's say
cubits
Elementary uh Quantum objects
per point in SpaceTime so there is an
infinite number but per point in space
time so you would get a number which is
proportional to the
volume um the blackall entropy formula
suggest this answer proportional to the
area so this prompted uh T and saskin to
say that in a theory of gravity the
basic fundamental degrees of freedom
that we should use to describe any
region of SpaceTime uh should scale like
the area of the region not not the
volume of the region as to naively
expect in in field Theory so that
suggest that gravity is a fundamentally
different kind of field Theory right and
I guess you know the idea of hologram
comes in because you know a regular
hologram thin piece of plastic you
illuminate it the right way you get a 3D
image from a two-dimensional flat piece
of plastic here the idea is you describe
say a volume in terms of degrees of
freedom that live on an area that
surrounds it the air
has one fewer Dimensions because it
doesn't have say the radial direction
that that goes within the volume itself
right that's right that's that's exactly
right and and so so with a t t and and
susine giving rise to this uh this
notion of holography that in a theory
with gravity the true degrees of freedom
really live on this bounding surface as
opposed to living Point by point in the
interior you really gave that idea legs
through the so-called ads CFT
correspondence I mean if you could
describe what that correspondence is and
and and then it's it's good to note how
it takes this idea of holography and
just makes it completely concrete right
right let me try to say it in the
following way
so you you could imagine this surface
being at the at the black hole Horizon
surface but you could also put it a
little bit further out right and still
you would describe the interior and you
could put it even a further out further
out and further out and if you put it at
the edge of the universe so as far as
you can uh then um then you can say what
kind of theory could live there so you
can give a more explicit description of
such a theory um because if you put it
on the surface of the black hole Horizon
it's a little tricky because some
particles can leave the interior of the
black hole to the exteror ior and if you
put a little further it's still some
things that can live it's hard to split
SpaceTime into two parts if you put it
far very far away then well everything
is inside that surface very far away um
and this works especially well in
universes where there is a gravitational
force that pushes everything to the
interior so this happens when the space
is curved in a very particular way uh
with constant negative curvature and
these space have a name they they're
called anti- theer so theer was Dutch
astronomer who considered the a space
with positive curvature but these are
spaces with negative curvature and so
some some they have a name they're very
simple very symmetric spaces and in this
spaces the gravitational the main point
is that the gravitational force pushes
everything to the interior so when you
put the surface further and further out
the particles that remain inside they
don't get
out and um so it gives you a
self-contained sort of box or system um
It's like a gravity
box and um and then uh the theory that
lives at the boundary is um a theory
similar to the theories we use for
particle physics so similar in spirit so
a theory of interacting fields that live
at the boundary or inter interacting
particles that live on the at the
boundary um so it's a bit like the
universe you could think of it as a
crystal ball where the surface of the
crystal is the region very far away and
the interior is that that whole universe
um and uh the idea is that that theory
that lives at the whole the boundary can
describe gravitational physics in the
interior and one important point I
forgot to mention is that this theory
that lives at the boundary does not have
gravity so it's a kind of quantum theory
that we know how to describe very well
so it's a theoretically sound
Theory and so just to just to give a
quick you know summary or summary yeah
part way Along on our discussion you're
claiming
that if someone lived on the the surface
of the crystal ball you way out there on
that surface say at the edge of the
universe and they were doing all of
their analysis using ordinary Quantum
field Theory without any gravity they
would give a complete description of
everything that a person in the interior
of this universe would come to using a
theory that has gravity so it's like two
distinct
descriptions one uses the ordinary tools
that we have developed over the course
of many decades tested at least the
framework not the exact Theory but the
framework within things like the Large
Hadron Collider and it gives answers
that would be completely the same
prediction by prediction as say A String
Theory with gravity in the interior of
that yeah that's that's that's that's
the idea so the idea is it's it's a
conjecture and it's a conjecture partly
because the strength theory in the
interior the theory of gravity is not
completely well defined so as we saw
it's a theory under construction and and
we know several well all the thing the
things that we can calculate they
agree well the things we can calculate
on both sides they agree um and um yeah
so so it's a conjecture and we well we
don't know how to prove it in complete
generality uh but Case by case it it
comes through and every calculation any
yeah so you can calculate you can
calculate consequences so you can um you
can consequences mean that there are
some calculations you can do in one
Theory and calculations you can do in
the other Theory and compare the answers
and and it's the agreement is amazing
people have done many many calculations
and they they found agreement and by
many many I know you're too modest to
say so I hope you don't mind me jumping
in I mean there have been tens of
thousands of followup studies of the
conjecture that you put forward I guess
it was 1997 1998 was when the first
paper was written and every single one
of those tens of thousands of follow on
only gave more evidence for the
conjecture that you put forward right so
it's um it's widely believed in the
field that this is true for that reason
so I I wanted to drill down a little bit
on its implications before uh going far
but did you want us go give anything
further on the on the basic idea itself
um no let's let's discuss some
implications yeah so so so there there's
so many directions that one can go but I
can't help but ask one which is we
started out in our discussion of string
theory noting that it's really tough to
test string theory and we didn't say at
the time but perhaps we should say it's
tough to test any theory that puts
gravity in want to mechanics together
because the place that you mentioned
early on the moment of the Big Bang or
the center of black hole these are such
extreme environments that we don't have
direct access to so it's just hard to
test a theory that really comes to life
in such an extreme domain but I'm
wondering the following once you
realized and once the physics Community
gave more and more evidence for the
likely possibility that string theory is
not as different as we once thought it's
not as radical a break as perhaps we
once thought from previous ideas because
as you just said you can describe string
theory in one Realm by Quantum field
Theory just in a different realm does
that in your mind shed slightly
different light on the question of
experiment because the framework of
quantum field theory has been tested to
Fantastic accuracy at least for certain
field theories doesn't that perhaps shed
a nice glow on string theory in that it
becomes much closer to experiment than
perhaps we once
thought yes yes I think one One
Direction that I think is very exciting
is the following so the this this field
theories that live at the boundary or
more General Quantum systems they are
they are strongly interacting so they
they need to be interact very strongly
and one exciting possibility is that we
could somehow artificially manufacture
in in a lab yeah some strongly
interacting Quantum system that might
have uh one of these emergent gravity
universes it wouldn't be a very big
universe it would be just small a few
few plank lengths and um but it could be
a universe that might be meaningfully
described by gravity so you would in
your lab uh arrange a bunch of atoms and
you know make them interact strongly and
so on and then predict Its Behavior
uh their behavior in terms of solving
Einstein's equations in some Universe
mightbe a higher dimensional universe
and so on and so you would be creating a
face of matter or some matter
configuration that uh really is being
described by by gravity yeah I think uh
that's uh that's very exciting I think
it's exciting first uh because it might
teach us new things about gravity
because we might simulate this and ask
we we we will be forced to ask new
questions about gravity we um we might
experimentally see some gravitational
phenomena that we we will then discover
how to describe theoretically and and
see exciting results do you think it's
do you think it's likely let me ask so
how difficult is this so exactly I one
can do an estimate so there is the there
are various examples of this adsf type
situation so you can look at the
simplest one to simulate and you can
estimate what's the smallest number of
cubits that you would need to uh have
something that you can describe by
gravity and people did some uh hanada
and collaborators did some Quantum some
computations using an ordinary computer
of the entropy of these systems and and
they found that with a certain with
about thousands of cubits um it would be
enough to uh to get results that match
gravity um now this number is more or
less the same number of cubits you would
need to break the codes the usual RSA
the usual you know usually when they say
quantum computers will uh you know break
the codes we use for internet
communication and so on in order to
really practically break them you need
the you need to have about you know
7,000 or several thousand cubits and a
number of operation there number of
operations you need to do is also
comparable between the black hole
example and and this uh this example of
uh of the breaking of codes so if if
quantum computers live to their promise
uh of you know
revolutionizing uh cryptography then uh
they will also revolutionize I think
quantum gravity yeah no that would be um
that would be utterly remarkable
fantastic uh I don't think it will
happen very any soon but I think maybe
in 30 years so if if
youate so that would be a sort of
wonderful you know way for this Theory
to develop let me get your thoughts
though on another connection potential
connection to experiment that people are
becoming
less optimistic about compared to
perhaps the way they were some decades
ago which was to find the so-called
super partner
particles that is REM that would reflect
the super symmetric quality the super
and super string theory is super
symmetry it's a as many in the audience
no doubt no it's a very abstract
symmetry principle that was really
discovered by physicist who were
studying string theory was then
generalized and applied to ordinary
Quantum field Theory as well one
implication of this symmetry is that for
every known particle there should be a
partner particle for the electron the
selectron quirks gorks and so forth and
I certainly had High Hopes as I think
most but not everybody in our community
did that the Large Hadron Collider after
finding the higs BOS on in 2012 the next
discovery that was going to be right
around the corner would be the discovery
of the super partner particles and that
has not yet
happened does that is that discouraging
to you or were you were the ones who
wasn't expecting success on that the
first place
well I was a bit disappointed but in the
following sense that um the simplest
theories we can understand are super
symmetric theories super symmetric
string theories um and if super symmetry
had been discovered then uh we would
already be in the realm of the things
that we already
understand the distance the number of
powers of 10 in between the plank scale
and the scales that we can measure today
is very big so super symmetry might be
broken anywhere in between and um so
didn't have to be discovered uh it would
have been nice if it was discovered
and one reason for expecting it at the
at the at the LHC was because of uh some
it would offer a natural explanation for
the value of the hix Mass yeah now we
know that um well there is no new
particle no no super symmetric particle
so the the value of the h mass is a bit
of a puzzle um there might be physics at
higher scales might do be super symmetry
beyond the the scales of that can be
measured by the laradon collider that
might explain or help to explain it but
it's not a completely natural value in
some sense yeah now we should quickly
say that it's not we don't know for a
fact that super symmetry it's not like
super symmetry has been ruled out it's
just become less likely because the
parameter space of possibilities has
been
shrinking as you know experiments have
gone forward but yeah well I'm not sure
it's less very less likely as a
fundamental symmetry of nature it could
be yeah I agree with that maybe equally
likely um it's just that well we it's
not that the scales of the LHC maybe
we'll have to work to the next
accelerator maybe maybe it's many many
more much higher scales yeah you mind if
I spend Focus yeah can I just just for
folks to understand the point that you
just made which is a very important one
super symmetry the symmetric quality
could still be a quality of the
underlying equations the underlying
mathematics it simply could be that it
doesn't manifest itself at energy scales
that we can currently access as you're
saying you just may need a more powerful
machine a more powerful machine and
maybe ultimately if it's powerful enough
you can access the particles that the
Symmetry requires to be there yes yes I
mean it's also possible that um there
are other theories of quantum gravity or
other regimes of even the quantum
gravity Theory we know that are not
super symmetric
in yeah for sure it's also possible so
so people are trying to understand
quantum gravity sort of in trying to
extract lessons from string theory that
might help us build a perhaps more
general theory of quantum gravity more
all encompassing one and where and and
and you mentioned other approaches now
of course you I know that you were
referring still to the universe of ideas
that swirl around String Theory but if
we just take a small diversion for a
minute or two there are other approaches
that people have developed for putting
gravity and quantum mechanics together
you know dynamical triangulations
perhaps Loop quantum gravity is the one
that may be most familiar to people who
are watching this you know there are
books that have been written about it
for General audiences and some of its
proponents are out there making clear
that they think that their approach is
perhaps the one that should be gaining
more attention than String Theory what
do you think about Loop quantum gravity
No Holds
Barred um well I think it it
um it's an approach that is based
essentially on um a canonical
quantization of gravity from to to three
plus one dimensions and trying to solve
all the constraints of gr yeah um and um
but I I think it's not as developed has
it's not as developed let's say as
String Theory maybe there might might be
developed in the future um
but it you you do not it does not
reproduce some very basic things like uh
you know luren symmetry in four
dimensions or higher dimensions and um
and you know the SC how gravit how
graviton scatter gravity waves scatter
with each other
uh you like to be able to calculate this
you can do that in string theory you
cannot do that in Des Theory um black
hole entropy these calculations of black
hole
entropy apparently gives maybe you have
to put in a new parameter to adjust it
so it it's um not not as uh developed
and as clear so um now I I think in in
the history of let's say strength Theory
there were sometimes things that were
viewed to be outside String Theory I
think a very good example is 11
dimensional super gravity yeah so there
was a time when there were a group of
people studying 11 dimensional
supergravity and then there were string
theorist at the same time and there were
the string theor well what you're doing
doesn't make sense because this theory
is not normalizable it's not and um
eventually it was understood that this
11 dimensional superg gravity is related
to strength there in some
way and uh yeah so that's an example
where an interesting idea that seemed
maybe not exactly right but then then it
was incorporated in in our more modern
understanding and um and like this there
were other other ideas like this uh yeah
and um and yeah maybe something like
that will happen with these other
approaches that eventually they might
there might be some element that uh will
be put in into more you know that will
be used in some way and you will find
the right place and in our theoretical
understanding yeah it's very diplomatic
and I I try to say similar things when
I'm put on the spot that way with some
uh unfair question I mean even roughly
speaking Loop and loop quantum gravity
it sounds like some kind of string--
like shape so you can't help but hear
the resonance between the words but yes
in detail it seems at the moment that
the theories are quite different quite
distinct but who knows like you say
maybe one day we'll find that there is
some way that these ideas contribute
maybe to even a a third theory that
we've yet to even come up with and in
the best world yeah there there are some
ideas that people are discussing now
something called tensor
networks which uh is some way of
originated some way of describing
complex Quantum States and now people
are uh thinking about SpaceTime in terms
of this tensor networks as for the
moment mostly as a qualitative idea yeah
and um and there there is some Bag
similarity with some of the ideas of luk
phantom gravity so I think yeah maybe
that might be the way there might be a
connection so there three other quick
things if you have time to uh briefly
talk about them if that would be all
right so you know some years ago and I I
no doubt some of our audience have read
about the so-called you know firewall
Paradox that emerg when people were
think thinking about black holes and
trying to square our understanding of
black holes with our understanding of
quantum mechanics most directly
understanding our understanding of
quantum entanglement the fact that you
know widely separated objects can be
somehow connected to each other and
there was an issue that arose in these
ideas creating quite a lot of tension
and thinking about black holes can you
just give us a a sense of what the issue
was and perhaps even where we stand now
in the
issue so I I think
uh the issue has to do um it's it's a
version of the HW in information Paradox
so that um we we we think that if we are
sitting outside the black hole and you
sending particles the hulking radiation
should carry the information that was
initially contained in these particles
yeah um so that that's what we think if
we think about for example adft or or we
think that we should have a unitary
description as seen from the outside
description according to Quantum
Mechanics I see from the
outside but on the other hand in general
relativity that matter that fell into
the black hole is still in the black
hole interior somewhere so you have on
one hand the information inside the
black hole interior and also the
information that is coming outside and
in quantum mechanics this is not
possible so you're not supposed to copy
Quantum information
soal the no Quantum cerox principle um
and so that's that's um roughly what
Hawkins problem is and here
they uh they translate the firewall
Paradox was really a paradox that
translated this problem into something a
little more measurable so where an agent
would collect information the Hawking
radiation that comes out of the black
hole and would distill some Quantum
beats that are entangled with uh the
bits that the black hole will emit in
the future and um and then someone could
uh take that that distilled Cubit and
fall into the black hole and check some
impossible pattern of
correlations of
entanglement and um yeah so that that
was the Paradox and it was called
firewall because they that was a
particular proposal that they had for
how to solve it um and I think nowadays
we think it would be solved in a
slightly different way so um and yeah
but in the process rather than giving
you a how we think uh it's going to be
solved um I would say that in the the
process of analyzing these questions we
understood better the the connection of
quantum entanglement and gravity and
also um there is something that we said
in the beginning that so we sit far away
we can describe all the all the space
time
uh all the SpaceTime inside this turns
out not to be completely right in the
sense that um you can describe all the
SpaceTime perhaps including part of the
black hole interior but in some
circumstances you cannot describe the
the other part of the black hole
Interior right so this so the limits of
what you can describe from outside were
more properly understood right and this
involves uh so one of the key let's say
workhorses in developing this new
understanding was a new formula for
Black Hole entropy and this is I think
something very important um so um which
is similar somehow similar to the area
formula of HW and beckenstein except
that it's not the area of the Horizon
but it's the area of some minimal area
surface and this is this formula is very
exciting because it gives us not the
thermodynamic entropy of the black hole
but the so-called Quantum entropy of the
black so the the the real total amount
of information that you get if even if
you do arbitr complex uh measurements um
so it's a kind of more precise and
sometimes called fine grain entropy
measure sometimes also called the
quantum information measure and so on um
yes so really getting at the heart of
what Quantum information is contained in
the black hole and it crucially depends
on the geometry of the black hole
interior so um the Hawking beckenstein
formula doesn't care about the geometry
of the Interior only the geometry
outside the Horizon um but this formula
really cares about the interior and in
certain cases
uh uh that entropy might be very small
in some cases might be large and so on
um and in this process of of taking a
surface and minimizing the area of the
surface you sweep somehow a region of
space time that includes the outside and
part of the interior and this whole
region is supposed to be the one that is
described by the theory outside by the
and so it gives us that region of the
geometry now what is described by what
is described in the other region and the
idea is that that other region is
described by whatever is entangled with
the black hole um so if you have a black
hole and Tangled some Quantum state with
something else then that other region is
described by something
else so so this gives this interesting
new picture I think it's a
generalization of the the previous sort
of adsf discussion um in the sense that
you could have separate Quantum systems
uh each describing a portion of some
some geometry um and um so and the
geometry could be completely connected
but uh but each each side is separate
and we have a Quantum state that is
entangled among the two sides yeah and
somehow it looks as if this entang
entanglement generates a geometric
Connection in the in the interior in the
interior of the black holes so that's
and and a closely related set of ideas
that that you've also developed has to
do with the connection between as you
mentioned entanglement quantum
entanglement and gravity through its
geometrical
Incarnation that is a connection between
two papers that Einstein himself wrote
193 5 the first of course is his epr
paper that used entanglement as a weapon
against quantum mechanics trying to
argue that it said that quantum
mechanics was not complete most people
now interpret it not as an actual
undercutting of quantum mechanics but
shedding a bright light on one of the
wonderful qualities of quantum mechanics
namely Quantum entang 1935 he also wrote
a paper on wormholes with Nathan Rosen
this idea that there can be shortcuts in
the fabric of SpaceTime between one
location and the other kind of tunnel
through the fabric of
SpaceTime your work suggests strongly a
connection between these two papers that
Einstein himself was not aware of can
you give us a feel for for what that is
right right so the yeah the this this
Einstein rosan paper is a paper of on
basically a paper trying to understand
better the geometry of the sh of the
solution yeah and the but they
what they discovered is that the
geometry really connects two separate
universes it's somehow connected
geometry kind of Wormhole as you said
between two universes but it is really
not traversable Wormhole so it's
something that you cannot use to send
signals yeah and the idea is that this
this geometry should be uh viewed as two
separate black holes so they have two
universes two black holes in each
universe but the quantum sites of these
black holes are entangled um
and uh that entanglement creates that uh
that connected geometry um so that's uh
that's the idea and
and
we well this idea has been made more
precise uh using this uh this
entanglement
formulas the original formula was due to
Ru and takayanagi and was improved by
many other authors and so now we we
understand a little bit better how this
works um I mean would you would you is
it too coarse to say that whenever there
is quantum entanglement there's some
kind of Wormhole like geometry right
right yeah at the at this time I think
it's too Co to say this um
so the thing is that um it depends on
what you call geometry If U if by
geometry you understand the a big space
described by Einstein's equations then
then the answer is no um
true so it's only particular patterns of
entanglement correspond to uh that those
geometries but not not anything of
course now there there's an open
question which is well is there a
generalization of geometry where where
this would be true but we don't know
that that
generalization so so final thing I'd
like to spend a moment on you know when
String Theory came along it suggested a
revision to some aspects of SpaceTime
for in instance as we discussed the
number of dimensions of space was
increased from the naive value of three
to say nine or 10 spatial Dimensions
depending on whether it's string theory
in the original Incarnation or the M
theoretic 11 dimensional supergravity
that you made reference to earlier
String Theory also suggested that these
extra Dimensions would have a rich
geometry curled up into some strange
shape called the cabia shape that we
also made reference to
earlier are we going further right now
is string theory and I work in quantum
gravity more generally is it suggesting
that space and time or space time itself
is not a fundamental ingredient in the
nature of reality and instead should be
thought of as some kind of emergent
feature that only really is relevant in
certain environments but more
fundamentally we should be able to talk
about physics in the absence of space
and
time um well I think in this in this
notion of uh ads CFT or these dualities
um at least some directions of space or
maybe all the directions of space uh are
emergent in this sense in the sense
they're not in the fundamental
description um that involves some cubits
for example and then you make the cubits
interact with each other you get some
higher dimensional space
um we don't have good examples where we
have merant time uh I think the interior
of a black hole is a situation where we
have some kind the time Direction in the
interior is in some sense imersion but
we don't understand it well enough um so
that that is part of the things we don't
understand and hopefully we'll
understand them soon
um and yes it it looks from this
description that the quantum mechanical
description is more fundamental and the
SpaceTime is looks like subordinate or
emerant what is ersion is certainly the
uh SpaceTime that is governed by Ein
equations so that only arises in certain
circumstances now the strength the
description is a description that uses
this SpaceTime and maybe some
modification of that space time so it
suggest that there might be a theory uh
that generalizes the notional SpaceTime
from which maybe the boundary Theory
might em
or so I I have not given up on a theory
that is described is described invol in
SpaceTime or or some internalization of
SpaceTime such as the one we have in
string theory but once you have
Duality once you have Duality say ADF
CFT where you've got these two distinct
descriptions one say involving one fewer
spatial Dimensions than the other so
these the geometrical settings within
which the quantum mechanical the quantum
field Theory description is is very
different from the geometrical settings
saying the gravitational and the string
theory description is that enough
perhaps to say that space at least is
not fundamental because if it is which
one would be the fundamental description
isn't it quite clear even at that dis at
that dual description that you've
entered a realm where the fundamental
ingredients are no longer describable in
terms of A
Spacetime
um well it could be that if you have the
interior space time and you sum over
many space times or you consider the
full quantum theory of those space times
then you might get the same answer so
it's a bit like uh you know so-called
FIA transform which is a way we have of
representing signals so you can give you
can give uh how the signal changes in
time or you can give all its frequency
components yeah we know that if we are
describing a signal you can give either
of these two descriptions and they would
be equally valid and um so it could be I
I think I think it might be something
similar that uh we we can have either
any of the two descriptions might be
valid and right saying if we if we use
the full Quantum description on the
quantum side and summed over all of the
geometries perhaps it all Blends
together in a way that yields some
unique geometrical description at least
in principle right right yeah no no yeah
and there are some very simple examples
in two Dimensions where something like
this was is been do I mean it's done and
and you you get the some sort of
boundary
description yeah so final question here
you know you I mean I've been fiddling
playing working on these ideas you know
since
1984 85 you've been doing as you
mentioned since
1990 are
you happy with where developments over
the last 30 years have taken us I mean
have we gotten as far as perhaps you
would have hoped way back when you were
starting out in
1990 um well I certainly hope we were
further along uh that we had I would
hope that we would
have an experimental prediction that we
can yeah measure and test and some
prediction for cosmology perhaps and um
on the other hand uh I think that
there's been a lot of progress things
that looked impossible or Out Of Reach
are have you know well especially in
this black hole
area certainly or or even even
regardless of black hole's understanding
strengths at very strong coupling and so
on um so there were many things that
were definitely mentioned as very
important open problems in you know in
the 80s or early 90s and and now have
been understood and yeah I hope the same
will happen with the problems that we
are now discussing like the interior of
black holes I think that's a problem
that hopefully there will be much more
progress and I think there's been some
progress through these entropy formulas
and we'll hopefully see more in the
future so overall
optimistic yes yes I think it's an
exciting area and uh well it's it's it's
a it's a long shot in the sense that
it's uh you know it's a very ambitious
uh program I think uh it's um leading to
interesting formulas interesting
mathematics interesting new ideas I keep
hearing new interesting ideas so that I
can't even keep with the interesting new
ideas they are proposing so it's it's
it's the field is moving and uh yeah I
think there will be yeah and in the end
in the end that's the the the right
barometer you know a theory that gets
stuck oopi it doesn't change it gets you
know set in stone strength theories is
malleable rapidly developing extremely
exciting collection of ideas that
ultimately we hope will coales into you
know one full
understanding of this Theory and getting
back to our initial questioning give us
an insight into the nature of the big
bang and how things really began or to
the Deep interior of a black hole so I
think that ultimately is is where we are
heading um so Juan thank you so much for
the the time fascinating conversation on
everything from Einstein unification to
black holes to holography to ads CFT to
Duality to the emergent nature of
SpaceTime so it's been a pleasure
speaking with you and and thanks so much
for joining us yeah it's it's great
talking to you and well greetings to
everyone listening excellent thank you
all right everyone that's about a wrap
here in our conversation with Juan
malesa a real rapid tour through the
last really we went all the way back to
1968 for a moment so over 50 years of
development in string theory which
remains a vibrant exciting fast-moving
field and we just have to recognize that
certain questions that we'd hoped to
have answered by today like a definitive
testable prediction that we just go out
and see whether or not these theories
are borne out by datas we'd hope to have
that by today but we don't but we're
still working hard to get there but we
have gotten insights into black holes in
nature
SpaceTime and the deep connection that
wand is responsible for between our
understanding of gravity on the one hand
and a theory without gravity but with
quantum mechanics namely a Quantum field
theory on a bounding surface of an
interior SpaceTime is such a remarkable
and Powerful Insight that it really has
set the course of string theory research
over the C course of 20 plus years and
we suspect that this is a key to
understanding the true nature of space
time gravity and matter so only time
will tell where all this will go but it
is certainly a fast-moving and exciting
field if you're interested in more on
this subject please subscribe to our
YouTube channel we had a another live
discussion here in New York City with a
number of leading string theorists Ed
Wht David Gross Andy strominger where we
covered somewhat similar as we did with
Juan but it's great to hear a variety of
opinions on the developments that have
characterized String Theory research
over the past 30 years we'll be
releasing that program I don't know
probably in the next few weeks I think
we're also going to be releasing a
program on artificial intelligence that
we did at that live event in New York
City as well as a whole series of other
programs as well as these live
conversations so if you want to know
what's going on please subscribe both to
our YouTube channel and also to the
world Science Festival newsletter so you
will be alerted when these programs are
both live and become available all right
that's all for now from New York City
Columbia University Brian Green for the
world Science Festival thanks for
[Music]
watching